limitar el aumento de la temperatura del
planeta a 15 grados celsius sobre los
niveles preindustriales el objetivo
clave para evitar una mayor catástrofe
climática como hacerlo reduciendo los
gases de efecto invernadero sobre todo a
través de la merma del consumo de carbón
petróleo y gas tres motores de la
economía internacional su costo unos 100
billones de dólares según el enviado
para el clima de naciones unidas y que
se haría haciendo una transición hacia
inversiones amigables con el medio
ambiente many green new world son muchas
energías renovables son ahora más
baratas que los combustibles fósiles y
tienen menos costos de operación a largo
plazo otras tecnologías verdes tienen
curvas de costo que han seguido bajando
de quini
point de muchas maneras simplemente es
más efectivo transformarse hacia lo
verde
ya un conglomerado de inversores bancos
y aseguradoras que representan un 40 por
ciento del capital mundial afirmaron
tener a su disposición 130 billones de
dólares para combatir el cambio
climático esto en el sector privado
cuando hablamos de los actores estatales
el llamado llega desde los países en
vías de desarrollo que denuncian el
incumplimiento por parte de las
economías avanzadas del objetivo de
entregarles anualmente 100 mil millones
de dólares para 2020 y así contribuir en
la lucha contra el cambio climático
si hay un compromiso político si hay una
voluntad hay un camino hemos
identificado todos los problemas todo el
mundo conoce los problemas pero hay una
falta de compromiso político con el
objetivo para 2020 sin cumplirse el
presidente de la cob 26 estima que entre
2021 y 2025 el total de la ayuda para
los países en vías de desarrollo llegue
a los 500 mil millones de dólares